we lost 6262 dollars on kickstarter and
raise ten thousand i wouldn't have made
season two and and we wouldn't be
talking right now I gave up so I raised
the money through a little shitty PayPal
buttons on her crappy I website and it
took six months and that's the other
thing about spike I think my money when
we think about fundraising how many
people are in your network how many
people do you know how many people know
you exist how many people are going to
find out about you while you're
fundraising now how much money is going
to come out of that number of
individuals because that was I think was
my mistake was that I thought that
trajectory that spike mentality was
going to go from the show to the
Kickstarter campaign to that 52 days and
we're gonna make it ten thousand dollars
and then and then after fundraise threw
up holidays that's great
we chased an actor five weezer for four
five six months big-time actor and it
got to a point just like her I get
thinks it I got a better schedule I'm
gonna miss everyone so we got another
actor and it worked out even better with
season two we were in discussions within
a company actually a few companies one
company particular that I thought we
were going to work with it seemed like a
really good fit it seems like
when somebody says I don't want to
produce your show over that's a that's a
good thing that's a good and so things
didn't work out and it took 11 months
for it to not work out and there were
other meetings and there's still other
things going on and but in the meantime
I wrote a really big show 150 160 pages
we were going from 15 to 20 minute
episodes to do six or seven of them cast
Sheryl Lee from Twin Peaks and can be
Robertson from being blocked Gary
Anthony Williams a lot of great actors
and then the company change they might
they decided they didn't work with us in
the direction you are go for whatever
reason and then the other things fell
apart all within a few days always funny
how at 11 months depth at it forever
Reed is dumb Oh so after I mourned what
you got to do get spend a little time
going damn it and then what I'm gonna do
next and and so I looked at what the
weaknesses were vampire mom and I needed
to have everything work for a short
amount of time it was a bunch of
I didn't want to make a project that was
so top-heavy so it was a giant
skyscraper foundation I wanted something
that I could scale I think I've had one
part of our part another part in sylhet
been so that's when I looked at his idea
play shorts of doing an anthology series
where it's not one story it's a bunch of
different stories that are sort of under
one heading it's my style what I do it's
comedy drama
yeah i think it's going to be more fun
and while I'm doing that I can keep
taking meetings I can keep building
audience for vampire mob and when that
it when that audience is big enough that
I think we can raise enough money to
shoot 150 pages then I'll try to but I
realize we're not that big we're not big
enough to make the money to get people
to shoot all that story for free that's
ridiculous that's crazy it's too and it
doesn't work it's not real and so I
didn't take my own advice I wrote myself
into a corner because I wanted to do
something better but it's not Mike I
made two seasons which 130 pages so I
have story out I want to make a bigger
story I don't want to make a smaller
story because I can't afford it I've
already have this kind of trajectory it
seems like that's the evolution of the
show in my mind so I so it's not working
out right now so i am using the marine
singing improvise adapt and overcome and
i am doing another show another store
I think it's an ebb and flow I think I
always expect obstacles so when they
come I'm not a surprise also when things
work out really quickly casting
cheryline commutes to McGary Anthony was
like nothing was like and I started
doing that when this company was
starting to drag their feet and it
seemed didn't seem like they were gonna
go at all and I'm like you know what
it I'm just gonna put a show
together so I started making calls I'm
like start hey you want to do the show
sending scripts and and then all sudden
like oh wow okay we could actually do
this like it seemed like if if
everything had worked the way I thought
it was going to work the way everyone
said it was coming to work
maybe what oh maybe it also maybe I look
maybe that would have been a giant
mistake but the thing about is that I
learned a lot of stuff during the time
that I was waiting for these to work out
I was reading I was watching I was
reading interviews blogs and shooting
some stuff and get hired by companies to
tell stories so there were other things
so now I'm coming back and I'm like so
great like I'm just want to get
to work tell some stories stop
waiting stop so next week I start
raising money and see what happens
you